installez-vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon
c'est la première fois qu'un de mes
invités sur splato arrive et ouvre
directement la zone
désolé vous aimez les surprises
voilà voilà voilà voilà je vous dis
voilà le rat il arrive comme ça et je
peux te dire et si Laura te bouffe le
cul tu vas voir il faut que j'aille
faire un tour
ça fait trois semaines alors
faut bien que ça arrive à un moment
dans notre groupe personne a fait caca
depuis 3 semaines
[Musique]
cher Victoria vous êtes levé pour nous
donc on va vous garder encore quelques
minutes si vous êtes d'accord on marque
une petite pause et on revient ça vous
va un petit café
j'ai créé une assise avec le tronc une
cuvette avec les pierres et j'ai creusé
un trou au milieu
c'est pas les premières toilettes que je
construis mais c'est les premières que
je fais en pierre ça fait très longtemps
que je suis pas allé aux toilettes
[Musique]
sympathique du tout voilà ce que va
composer Lully pour la guérison de la
fistule du roi
joie le roi de la joie exactement il
peut s'asseoir sur son auguste
postérieur là on entend une version au
piano mais évidemment c'est un orchestre
qui joue et à l'occasion de cette
représentation Lully est un musicien
encore une fois exceptionnel il y a un
musico qui est un peu à la bourre
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment est-ce qu'on donne le tempo à
l'époque par une baguette avec un grand
morceau de bois comme ça on tape sur le
sol et qui fait du bruit et là il est
tellement énervé qu'il tape en disant il
va y aller lui c'est un peu comme Louis
de Funès vous voyez dans la BIM un coup
sur le pied gangrène et en mourir ouais
tout ça pour ça quoi tout ça pour une
fistule
c'est un moyen de pression bien visible
à l'odeur nauséabonde qui déborde sur
les trottoirs de la capitale des
centaines de sacs poubelles que cette
restauratrice voit s'accumuler un peu
plus chaque jour on avait pensé pendant
un moment à
se stocker mais en fait on peut même pas
Paris c'est censé être la ville de
lumière la ville des amoureux c'est pas
très romantique en une semaine
4400 tonnes de déchets n'ont pas été
ramassés c'est ici sur les bancs rouges
de l'assemblée que le gouvernement
connaîtra donc quatre jours le sort de
sa réforme face à lui des opposants de
gauche et un arbitre la droite des
républicains l'épilogue de plusieurs
mois de tractations qui auront crispé
l'opinion
une première manche a été remportée hier
soir au Sénat par le gouvernement
pour 195 contre 112 le Sénat à adopté
après le vote du Sénat hier c'est un
autre défi qui attend le gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne mercredi une
commission mixte paritaire composée de 7
députés et de 7 sénateurs doit proposer
une nouvelle version du texte qui sera
soumise au vote des sénateurs le jeudi
matin puis des députés l'après-midi mais
le gouvernement a-t-il une majorité vous
avez choisi un slogan de campagne et de
livres assez surprenant les jours
heureux sont devant nous c'est de la
naïveté c'est finalement un acte de foi
c'est se dire regardons devant nous il y
a des choses encore merveilleux à vivre
et à faire
on a besoin de réformes heureuses à
l'Assemblée les députés Renaissance
modem et horizons sont 250 pour
atteindre la majorité à 287 voix le
gouvernement compte donc sur le
ralliement des députés républicains mais
seul 35 envisagerait de voter la réforme
le compte n'y serait pas le gouvernement
pourrait-il alors être tenté d'utiliser
l'article 49-3 une option pour l'instant
rejetée par la majorité rien n'interdit
au gouvernement d'utiliser le 49.3 mais
les conséquences politiques seraient
considérables
le président sait que le 49-3 abîmerait
durablement sa première ministre et que
son vote les syndicats penseront que la
mobilisation peut se poursuivre dans la
rue souligne un ministre il y a un vrai
projet de société là sur la
confrontation que nous avons sur la
réforme des retraites où nous faisons du
travail une source de profit où nous
faisons du travail un moment qui permet
à chacun de répondre vos besoins du pays
de relever les défis qui sont devant
nous à un moment de bonheur et
d'émancipation
et comme ça
c'est vous madame attendez comment vous
vous appelez madame ça va Nassima c'est
votre vrai rire ça vous avez pris du
gaziland
et donc parler de bonheur remettre
l'être humain au cœur de la société
mettre les moyens pour ça les immenses
richesses que nous créons qui sont les
nôtres mais c'est ça les jours heureux
c'est un projet de société pour le
plaisir
prendre le temps de temps en temps de
refaire d'un âme un enfant et s'éblouit
[Musique]
c'est marrant c'est à mi-chemin entre le
dauphin
[Applaudissements]
il y a le dauphin il y a la jument aussi
d'être venu ce soir merci beaucoup
méditer sur ce sujet évidemment ce
weekend